welcome to CBS this morning Bernie
Sanders is a winner of New Hampshire's
first-in-the-nation Democratic
presidential primary
the Vermont senator who beat Hillary
Clinton soundly in New Hampshire four
years ago narrowly defeated former mayor
Pete Budaj
26 to 24% senator Amy Klobuchar finished
a surprising third ahead of senator
Elizabeth Warren and former Vice
President Joe Biden but CBS News
estimates that Sanders and Budaj edge
will each win nine of the 24 delegates
up to up for grabs and that means that
Budaj edge still has the most delegates
overall after his razor thin victory in
the Iowa caucus last week ed O'Keefe is
in Manchester New Hampshire and good
morning long night what did we learn
sure was Tony good morning after the
mess in Iowa New Hampshire brought some
welcomed clarity to the race for
president there were clear winners and
losers with some campaigns throwing in
the towel and others getting out of here
as fast as they could and moving on to
the next contests senator Bernie Sanders
claimed victory and Democratic
frontrunner status in the Granite State
this victory here is the beginning of
the end for Donald Trump his closest
competitor former mayor Pete Buda judge
congratulated his opponents but noted
he's here is stag one day books will
tell not just of one election but of the
era that began with you here in New
Hampshire but it was senator Amy
Klobuchar third-place finish that
couldn't have been predicted until the
last few days Donald Trump globish I
wrote a wave of momentum after a strong
performance and last Friday's debate I
came back CBS News exit polls found half
of Democratic primary voters in New
Hampshire decided under candidate in the
last few days 29% of those who waited
went with Budaj
and 24% clover sure Wow Sanders led
among those who decided earlier we are
taking on billionaire's
and we're taking on candidate
it's funded by billionaires it was a
disappointing finish for senator
Elizabeth Warren though she vowed to
move forward our campaign is built for
the long haul just getting started and
sensing a poor finish former Vice
President Joe Biden fled New Hampshire
early for South Carolina where he
believed so have more support it ain't
over man we're just getting started but
for some candidates they decided it was
over businessman Andrew yang who
qualified for all but one democratic
debate announced he's suspending his
campaign you know I am the math guy and
it is clear tonight from the numbers
that we are not going to win this race
also dropping out Colorado Senator
Michael Bennet and former Massachusetts
governor Deval Patrick is expected to
exit the race later today the campaign
moves on next to the Nevada caucus and
the South Carolina primary Anthony we
have no idea who will win this much I
know it will be much warmer where we're
going good for you ahead thanks